what's the deal with airplane peanuts
everyone knows Shane Gillis and Theo Von
are two of the funniest comedians
working today but after Shane's third
appearance on this past weekend and
Theo's recent visit to Matt and Shane's
podcast already surpassing 1 million
views on its way to becoming their
second most viewed episode only behind
Louis CK Shane Gillis and Theo Von are
arguably the entire internet's two
favorite comedians and these are the top
five moments between theovon and Shane
Gillis starting all the way back on
August 14th 2021 with their first ever
public conversation on this past weekend
yeah and that's yeah that's our producer
Riley M he's never even masturbated in
his life which is true and that's Riley
the the G you never masturbated
never give it a shot nuh no no you can't
he's like it's too late now no he no
it's not too I don't think it's too late
I don't know hopefully he can I don't
know he might have autism I don't even
know him that well he's a great great
guy and I'm glad that he's here uh sorry
I didn't mean to bring that up it just
kind of fell in the conversation that
and uh are you doing okay Riley I am
there you go you just never masturbated
no he's he's part of a religious group
and they don't do it how what type of
religion uh Christian oh [__] yeah I'm
with you brother but I'm still fir him
off he's with you you're more of a
Hester I was a Catholic and they would
talk to you about coming you grew up
Catholic right do you uh or we were like
sixth Baptist I think oh okay you ever
get any guys talking to you about come
we had a professor I guess or I think
then it was just a teacher you know yeah
and he would I remember he drew a
picture of a wiener ejaculate all
chalkboard and it was he like kind of
described like he told us what the
feelings would be like we wouldn't be
able to handle it in stuff and then he
he drew the yeah the ejacula just coming
out it was really really insane was he
like was he like making the noise with
it I remember he would put the marker on
the board and then walk it across that's
crazy and he wore the shortest shorts
too he died man Willie I think Derek
usner was his name or something and I
think his son might have died but he
died but his son died too I I'm pretty
uh I don't want to say that but I'm
pretty sure and he had the biggest
mustach like I don't his words like I
feel like his words big mustache and he
was talking bro his mustache came over
were both lips so it was like he's dead
the words couldn't even some of the
words you just had to guess what they
were people thought he was some people
thought he was black people didn't know
what was going on it was
dicey well we just couldn't understand
what he was talking about you know it
was just different times back then um
different times but yeah I've never
really had an experience really old with
a older woman coming in at number four
is fio Von's first appearance on Matt
and Shane secret podcast I drink a lot
come back here late yeah guns just want
to show everybody the gun I got dude you
have to you play with it play with it in
your room that's how Chris died dude
it's not loaded who everybody's a of
Chris that died
like I yeah if I have a gun I'm going to
shoot it at that fence oh you have to
dude and and you know he's going to be
walking by that fence when you shoot
don't you no Chris Chris shot it's just
everybody has a friend of Chris had died
from some gun
accident and I hate to even laugh about
it man it [__] sad I know it's sad
for a lot of people right now hearing
that and just makes me [__] sad I
don't pay attention to things at all
what are you talking about man you're
just carrying a handgun cuz you can car
you can bring your own gun to the thing
yeah I know how you I know having a how
having a Gun Works what I'm saying is
how do you drop a [__] gun I I don't
pay attention my head's in the clouds
all the time were you holding it yeah I
was [__] holding it you were walking
back to your car holding the pistol you
didn't holster it or put it in like a
case carrying the pistol back yeah just
straight in the air cuz I'm going in my
[__] car now now now I'm try to
remember why I didn't put in a case but
I remember dropping it to where like it
hit the asphal I was like a [__] scratch
it's heavy it's probably scratched what
the [__] I scratched go off dude well
the whole thing my it was after my wife
was like she can actually shoot so she
was teaching me and I'm like dude get
the [__] off me and I'm like so I was
already an all time low wait was she
rapping around oh yeah she trained she
was [__] police she was an officer
you don't get trained that way it's sexy
dude it is sexy it's se but no for real
I was like get off me like stop you're
embarrassing there's a bunch of like AR
man baby true that's love dude but then
I was like I'm carrying the gun I wanted
to assert my manhood so I'm like I'm
carrying the gun to the car I I think I
was just like [__] check in the
chamber this is just mixed love man is
what this is yeah this sounds like every
mixed relationship I've ever
even there's not one mixed couple that
hasn't dropped a gun in a parking
lot yeah but that's funny did she laugh
no she was like this I told you I should
have carried it's like I know how to
[__] carried I had one laugh I have
[__] butter fingers
relax I had [__] popcorn earlier I
thought I saw someone coming at
us D dude it was ridiculous dude at
number three on this list is the time
Shane Gillis made his return to this
past weekend back in May of 2022 I went
to a basketball game once and like gave
a flower to a girl at the game like when
she was in the stands did that and it
was like people were yelling you know
people were yelling the N word dude I
think your ass like it was like if I saw
a dude do it yeah even though I I have
done
it if I saw someone else giving a flower
to a girl I'd be like [__] be so fun I
think I [__] yeah it got
stck bro it was so crazy and I had so
much acne at the time I was afraid to
move my face cuz I thought a lot of the
acne would pop out of my skin that's
crazy how to go with the flow did she
like it it went fine man I feel like it
doesn't work like anytime you go crazy
like that and like try to do and over
the top top romantic thing with a girl
you're not dating oh yeah like if you're
like I want to date you I got you this
bouquet yeah it's like no oh dude they
had uh I remember I used to work with
this one guy named Thomas and he sent
this girl like the biggest cinnamon cake
ever and I'm like what is a cinnamon
cake first of all and uh risk oh
horrible R and she thought he was insane
yeah she he sent it to a bar she worked
at so she gets to her bar shift and
there's a huge somebody sent you this do
you know yeah she's like barely you got
me a
cake and he has to sit there waiting
like yeah I wonder how this is going
he's probably loving that [__] cake
he just gets a text like never call me
again [__] sitting back launching a cake
and sitting back and being like ins this
is going to go well and then never
hearing from the woman again yeah just
drop it you forget about it and now you
can't even go to the bar anymore oh
never again that's the crazy never again
that bar is gone you got to burn it down
you got to go that night and set fire to
it so far we've seen three of the
funniest Shane and Theo moments but
number two is truly Next Level 511 I
guarantee you there is a predomination
of gays at a certain height I believe it
yeah can you look that up you guys don't
have anybody that works here huh gay
height no we got we
got get the guy [__] this is fire up
the computers dude crunch the numbers
all you got him was a [__] canister
of blood pressure medicine and a cell
phone to look stuff up
on it's on crack Squad dude these guys
are good ask him anything ask him
anything right now L May doesn't need a
computer he knows true did you hear that
rock question he got it right Weir when
did The Rock come back 2012 he is a
computer that is an autistic man oh my
for real we do not need computers he's
yeah I feel you dude he's the mind of a
machine start doing uh like now they do
horsepowers they might start doing like
autis autis powers on the computer oh
that'd be great movie
huh autism Powers would autism Powers
you make me horny
yeah autism powers do I make you
uncomfortable
baby atis Powers just an american guy
dressed like Austin Powers at a ComiCon
yeah yeah it's just one of our
politicians dude how crazy that our po
that the politics now they're just
blatantly just stealing money and
smelling and molesting children it's
crazy dude no one cares there's nothing
we can do about it we realize even if we
voted there's nothing we can do about it
nothing we can do about it we're all
trapped in this [__] just this money
funneling all our money to [__] fight
Wars it's literally like a game of likei
like a risk or one of those it's like a
computer game someone's playing and
they're so close to beating it though
they're so close to beating the game we
just need to dude they need like 60
trillion more dollars from us dude and
we're going to win once we save Ukraine
we're we're back true and the number one
moment on this list is from episode 478
of this past weekend which came out in
January of 2024 and already has a
whopping 2.3 million views precisely
showcasing the insane poll that this Duo
demands really it makes you feel that
like you like every time you show up
you're like oh I'm hung over until you
start to notice a pattern you mean oh
yeah for sure yeah drinking too much
that's but I love it I love it dude I
can't there's there's no part of me
that's like all right stop oh yeah just
like no you got it that's what you tell
yourself you got n then you're fully in
control no man you're good you're in
complete control dude one time we were
drinking with my buddy and uh he got
into the Uber right and he just didn't
get his like he had like real kind of
heavy legs cuz his mom kind of had heavy
legs but she wor tight pants and you
kind of couldn't tell but if you were
over there a lot you knew yeah that she
kind of had really stocky legs and but
he was bringing his second leg into the
Uber and his sandal fell off right so
then we had this place we go he [__]
shows off no yeah everybody was just
like he just seems so much drunker than
he was you know it's crazy I lo yeah
that's yeah losing one piece of Footwear
and somebody's like oh that guy like a
lens of a glasses one lens you're
[__] Hammer dude you're got crackhead
now oh yeah that's that's insane I feel
like losing glasses ly you got to really
yeah your kids are like nuh-uh yeah yeah
your kids are like we're not we're going
to order
pizza forever it's Pizza time let me
know in the comments what your favorite
moment from this list was or which
moments we may have missed and shout out
to Matt mccusker for some of these
hilarious moments as well as always feel
free to fill out the form in the joke
World Instagram bio to claim some free
joke World stickers if you fill up that
form we'll send these to your house free
of charge thank you so much for watching
oh thanks everything he said it's funny
oh dude no I have less posture like my
body style
yeah joke
world and it world is wld
D that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out